hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the debate rages on in congress over
what should be included in the next
coronavirus relief bill
and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell says he supports another round
of stimulus checks
but kentucky senator rand paul is
speaking out against fellow republican
spending recommendations
raising concerns about a rising national
debt
the lawmaker joins the rundown to
discuss what pandemic relief he thinks
is necessary
and the trump administration's decision
to send homeland security officers to
portland oregon
in response to violent protests is
sparking criticism from local leaders
who call it an abuse of power
fox news senior judicial analyst judge
andrew napolitano weighs in on this
and coronavirus-related lawsuits
regarding schools returning in the fall
plus commentary from former assistant
u.s attorney and fox news contributor
andy mccarthy
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm charles payne i'm martha mccallum
i'm greg jarrett and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday july 22nd 2020
i'm lisa brady both sides in washington
now say
more coronavirus relief is needed for
the economy
but how much is enough one republican
senator says his colleagues
shouldn't lose their souls on spending i
don't think that we should throw out
good sense
and believe in something the opposite of
what we believe in because of this
virus i'm chris foster about federal
troops in portland oregon and president
trump threatening deployments in more
cities fox news
senior judicial analyst judge anna
napolitano says the
federal government cannot deploy any
force
other than on its own property and
certainly can't deploy forces for
domestic law enforcement
without the express request of the
governor and i'm andy mccarthy i've got
the final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
a new pandemic prognosis from the
president
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
something i don't like saying about
things but that's the way it is
in his first white house coronavirus
briefing since the spring
the president also making a direct
appeal on masks
urging people to wear one when they
can't socially distance
whether you like the mask or not they
have an impact they'll have an effect
and we need everything we can get
california on tuesday becoming the
second state to talk
400 000 cases of the virus second only
to the former u.s epicenter
new york and as some states continue to
set new single day records and
roll back reopenings the white house and
congress are working on another relief
bill
we've spent an unprecedented money the
good news is a lot of the three trillion
dollars we still have left to put in the
economy and put back to work
we're focused on starting with another
trillion dollars we think that will make
a big impact
treasury secretary steve mnuchin said
that during an oval office meeting
monday
then told reporters on tuesday we'll
spend what we need to spend
house speaker nancy pelosi says a
trillion dollars won't be enough
the democrat-led house already passed a
three trillion dollar relief package
i guess the question is is it a good
idea to borrow money to try to stimulate
an economy
kentucky senator rand paul says a caucus
with fellow republicans tuesday
sounded like it could be a meeting of
bernie bro progressives
republicans typically would have said no
that was more the philosophy of bernie
sanders and the democrats to borrow
money to try to stimulate the economy
there is no rainy day fund in washington
there is no savings account there's no
money that you can
give to people and yet people keep
promising as politicians are want to do
promising free money to people this
latest bill they're talking about is
over a trillion dollars and that's
before
they start compromising with the
democrats to give the democrats what
they want
so i think it's a foolhardy notion to
think that you can just create money out
of thin air give it to people
and that that creates wealth the reason
we're struggling as a country is because
the government
has created a depression by shutting the
economy down forcibly the governors
primarily
the only way you get it back is not by
giving people money by
actually opening the economy is the only
way we'll survive and recover
some would argue these are very
extenuating circumstances
i know there was a gop caucus meeting
tuesday though and
to say the very least you came out of
that meeting sounded
sounding pretty disappointed you said
we're losing the country
what do you say to someone who might
consider that to be an overreaction
well we've added four trillion dollars
three trillion dollars to the debt
um for coronavirus plus a trillion
dollars just in
annual debt that we accumulate because
we spend more than comes in so we're at
four trillion
we had another trillion trillion and a
half two trillion we're looking at about
five
trillion dollars of additional debt in
one year um
you ask any republican six months ago
wouldn't be a good idea to add five
trillion to the debt
no every republican in the land
complained about president obama
you know increasing the debt from 10 to
20 trillion over eight years
now they're willing to increase the debt
over five you know five trillion dollars
in six months
no it's it's absurd it's obscene and if
deficits were bad and a danger to the
economy and president obama they're just
as much of a danger just
because we have a pandemic doesn't make
deficits any less dangerous to the
economy
is there a level of quote-unquote relief
or spending that you would consider to
be necessary at this point i mean
you've mentioned opening up the economy
is really what needs to happen to help
but how do you do that well you
the governors should be told that it's
unconstitutional to forbid businesses
from
opening and businesses should be allowed
to open
and customers should be allowed to
choose and make their own risks
this is a recession and a vast
unemployment caused by government
so you have to know what the cause is if
the cause is government government needs
to reverse what it's doing
but simply printing money and borrowing
it and giving it to people who still
have jobs
i mean it was a crazy notion from the
beginning to send twelve hundred dollars
to people who already had jobs
the reason they weren't spending money
was because not because they lacked
money
it's because you closed the economy down
and told them they couldn't go to stores
they couldn't go anywhere
and so really this is entirely created
by the government
and the government needs to quit doing
what they're doing which is clamping
down on the economy and will survive
just fine
but going into debt is something that
republicans used to be opposed to
and i think it's great hypocrisy that
republicans now
have become basically the champions of
bernie sanders economic plan
we did have the beginnings of an
economic reopening though right and in
many parts of the country and now we're
seeing
a surge in cases of coronavirus in
a good part of the country so what about
the concerns i've seen sir we've seen
surges and coronaviruses in the midst of
lockdown
new york had a lockdown and had 30 000
people die
new york had the worst death rate of any
place in the world
amidst a lockdown so perhaps a lockdown
didn't do any good and perhaps the
lockdown
killed our economy but didn't do
anything to stem the tide of the
virus so i see nothing to be admired in
new york's lockdown i see
you know a mountain of people who died
particularly in the nursing homes
but i don't think they lockdown did them
any good i think it killed the economy
but didn't do any good for
trying to contain the virus so to the
states that are rolling back
some reopenings and tightening
restrictions now what should they be
doing
to address health concerns instead is it
all about masks
i think that uh each individual needs to
assess their own risks
with regard to the virus for those under
18 the risk of mortality is
about one in a million or a little bit
less for those ages 18 to 45
it's about 10 out of 100 000 as a
mortality rate
so really we need to put it in context
under age 45
this uh disease we're looking at is less
dangerous than the seasonal flu
above age 45 it's more dangerous than
the seasonal flu
if you're in your 80s and you're in a
nursing home we need to do
all kinds of things to try to protect
you but i don't think that involves
shutting down the economy
i think that involves other precautions
we typically have
among us tens of thousands of people who
are on chemotherapy
but we don't tell the whole country to
wear masks because you might give a
virus to people
horn chemotherapy what we do is people
on chemotherapy tried to be very
cautious to stay away from
children with infectious diseases or
others who might transmit it
but we don't shut the entire economy
down even though there are tens if not
hundreds of thousands of people with
depressed immune systems
so i think we've made a big mistake in
the lockdown
we've crippled the economy but i don't
know that we've done much to the virus i
think the virus actually
is going to get to the point of some
level of immunity
in the southern states before debates
and i think that's what happened in new
york
the interesting story that most people
aren't reporting is that new york's not
doesn't have many deaths at this point
and doesn't have many new cases and
people say oh that's because governor
cuomo is such a great governor
nope has nothing to do with him i think
it has to do with it new york city
in particular has now achieved a level
of immunity that there is somewhat of a
somewhat of a tampening tamponading of
the virus because of a level of immunity
same is happening in stockholm same's
happening in probably northern italy
where a huge number of people have
gotten it and the virus has run its
course and probably won't come back
in a significant fashion as they did the
first time
are we at a point with this virus though
where people are so concerned
that they may sound a little like the
treasury secretary that all
bets are off that whatever needs to be
spent should be spent i mean
is the public sentiment turning that way
to the point where
do you feel like arguing against more
spending is kind of a losing argument
politically
i don't think that we should throw out
good sense and
believe in something the opposite of
what we believe in because of this
virus so republicans traditionally felt
that
debt could get to a point where it's a
real burden on the economy
many people worried about you know our
debt getting to be 100
of our gdp we're now exceeding that and
there have been many who have said and
argued that it will slow economic growth
and ultimately
that you can even destroy your currency
and so yes i think all those are still
valid worries
and i don't quit worry about them i
don't adopt the
philosophy this new monetary philosophy
of the progressive democrats because of
a virus
if you are sincere in your beliefs that
big government and debt are a problem
you should continue to have those
beliefs we shouldn't throw out our
beliefs because of this pandemic
the other thing is is that i think that
many of the things we've done have not
worked
and the people we're lauding are people
who actually made catastrophic decisions
i think
governor cuomo should be impeached you
know for what he did for the disastrous
decision he made to send patients with
coronavirus back to nursing homes
and virtually half his people who died
were in the nursing homes
same with new jersey so terrible public
health policy decisions were made
and i think in the end none of these
policies have probably been good for our
economy or actually good in containing
the virus
a study released by new york's health
department this month
linked most nursing home deaths to
infected staff
not the governor's order to accept covet
patients though
some health care workers and scientists
dismiss the report as just an effort to
shift blame
as for restrictions and lockdown
policies governor cuomo has hailed new
york's efforts to slow the spread
our hospitalizations are at the lowest
level since
march 18th the former u.s epicenter of
the virus now averaging
around 700 new cases per day compared to
thousands in surging states
but nationwide the biggest number of
deaths in one day since early june
over a thousand in the reuters tally for
tuesday
and many people are scared about both
their health
and their jobs so could republicans
risk losing the senate by not spending
more on relief
if that's what the voters say they want
what if republicans decide that they're
going to be democrats and they say well
we'll offer you more money than the
democrats do you think that's going to
encourage
you know the base of the republican
party to want to vote for candidates
frankly i'd stay home if that's the
choice between democrats who will
bankrupt you tomorrow
and republicans that'll bankrupt you the
day after tomorrow
so uh frankly no i don't think that our
base and our people want to spend more
money and i think frankly
if you talk to people who have
traditionally supported republicans
they still are fiscal conservatives they
think the economy should open they think
this has been an overreaction
closing the economy down and they think
that our only route to back to economic
prosperity
is to get rid of the draconian
governor's rules
that have uh impaired commerce is this
issue this issue of spending is it a
missed opportunity
for the president in your eyes because
in in the midst of all of this
joe biden has just released a third part
of his
economic recovery plan and i think he's
up to about a three trillion dollar
price tag so far
the problem is is that if both parties
support
vast amounts of borrowing vast amounts
of additional debt
uh there becomes less distinction
between the parties and it doesn't
motivate people to
vote one way or the other so no i think
republicans shouldn't lose their soul
over this and i think many republicans
are in the ones that are in washington
are losing their souls but i hear from
republicans at home who say
open the economy let us get back to work
but don't just keep putting up money
don't become like the democrat
simply because of this virus kentucky
senator rand paul
thank you so much for your time thank
you
[Music]
this is andy mccarthy with your fox news
commentary
coming up president trump says if mayors
and governors can't stop violence in
their own cities he'll do it for them
so far sending federal homeland security
officers to portland oregon
portland was totally out of control the
democrats the liberal democrats running
the place had no idea what they were
doing
they were ripping down for 51 days
ripping down that city
destroying the city looting it portland
mayor ted wheeler says the federal
officer's presence has escalated the
situation and he wants him gone
before the federal troops got here
violence was way down
vandalism was way down our local and
state law enforcement officials had
contained the situation
a group of mayors including portland has
written to attorney general william barr
asking for justice department and
homeland security reviews of the
officer's use
chicago mayor lori lightfoot says she'll
go to court if necessary to stop it
there
an administration source tells fox news
there are no plans to deploy in more
cities but
the president says he's considering it
if necessary if we just look at portland
as an example
it's unlawful and it's unconstitutional
fox news senior judicial analyst judge
internapolitano it's unlawful
because federal law and the constitution
itself
require that the federal government
cannot deploy
any force other than
on its own property and certainly can't
deploy forces for domestic law
enforcement
without the express request of the
governor of the state in which the
forces are to be deplored or the
legislature of the state and neither is
the case here
yes it's also unconstitutional because
these
federal agents have been arresting
people or what purports to be an arrest
it's more likely
it's more better it's better
characterized as a kidnapping
uh because they are they are restraining
people and locking them up without
arrest warrants or without probable
cause
probable cause would mean that they
weren't act that the officer doing the
arrest actually saw a crime being
committed these people are being
restrained for two hours and then
let go we know there's no probable cause
because none of them has been charged
with anything this
is just an effort to intimidate people
from engaging
in lawful dissent now is there unlawful
behavior going on of course there is is
it destructive of property yes it is
is there is it within the authority of
the portland
officials to restrain their police well
it's within their legal authority but
it's not within their mall authority
because the job of the police is to
protect lives and property
and if they don't do so people will
start using force to protect their own
lives and property and that's really
going to ratchet things up
well the acting dhs secretary homeland
security secretary chad wolfe says that
look we have a mandate and a duty to
protect
uh federal assets like courthouses
however as we've seen
there have been detentions i guess again
we can't call them arrests because
there's
i don't think there's a record of them
nowhere near federal property people
just walking down the street say they've
been snatched up by unmarked rental good
bike
by officers and unmarked rental cars
well that's that's criminal that's
that's kidnapping these officers could
actually i don't think this will happen
because it'll be force against force on
a public street
but these officers are exposing
themselves to arrest by
portland police and oregon state police
can they fly to
an airport and be deployed on federal
property
to keep people from destroying federal
property absolutely can they travel from
the airport to the federal property from
wherever they're spending the evening
the federal property of course they can
can they wander the streets and do
whatever they want under the guise of
enforcing local law
absolutely not that itself is a crime
so for chad wolfe and you quoted him
very accurately
chris to say law and order this is
anything but lawful
and it's profoundly chaotic it's not
orderly at all
so even if let's say new york city mayor
bill de blasio told the police
stand down we don't care what anybody
does it's the purge people can run
around
and do whatever they want federal
officers still have
no legal authority to come in and do
anything about it
unless the new york state legislature or
the governor of new york asks them to
come in
that's not me interpreting the law
that's crystal clear
in article two of the constitution uh
moving on to this new coronavirus relief
package they're working on president
trump
and republicans in the senate are
insistent that this thing includes
um corona virus liability protection
uh for businesses now you can sue for
safety violations can congress
pass a law this narrow saying you can't
sue
over this virus it's very difficult for
congress to do that because
lawsuits over public accommodation
safety or workplace safety or state
lawsuits based on state law
and they're filed in state courts so
congress would have to
what's called co-opt the field congress
would have to take away
from the states the ability to regulate
and to and to adjudicate issues
involving uh coronavirus and put them
all in federal court and then tell the
federal courts to throw them out
those are two enormous leaps which would
generate
huge constitutional challenges it would
be profoundly unjust for the congress to
bar you
from bringing a lawsuit you have every
right where there's a wrong there's a
remedy
you have every right to commence a
lawsuit and you have to prove your case
you have to prove
that it was the negligence of the owner
or occupier of the land that you visited
for a commercial purpose for congress to
interfere with that
is profoundly unjust and will cause many
innocent people to go without redress
and just questionably constitute
unconstitutional because as i said these
are state areas
involving state regulations of local
property
i know you're saying that well you have
to prove your case but what about if
there's just a deluge of cases of people
getting sick
well that's the price you pay for living
in a free society is that there's a
deluge of
of lawsuits chris you know lawyers have
a duty
to investigate the lawsuit before they
file it and they can't
at least at least ethically file a
lawsuit that they can't prove
so if a person was in five public
accommodations in one day and five days
later
got the virus and and there are damages
you know it's not sniffles as the
president calls it but there are damages
you can't you can't sue somebody because
you've got a cold
you can only sue somebody if you if they
have caused you or arguably caused you a
demonstrable quantifiable loss
it is the duty of the lawyers bringing
the case
to prove the cause of the quantifiable
loss
you can't just say here's the five
places i went to now you five fight it
out
you lose the case will be dismissed and
you'll be charged
with filing a pr a frivolous complaint
and rightly so
uh let's talk about mask orders that's
there in more than half the states now i
don't have the number off top of my head
but more of them
who's in charge of public health and
safety can is it the governors is it
localities can a locality say look
um i want masks here and the governor
say no as has happened in georgia
well under the constitution the states
are in charge of health and safety
different states have different state
constitutions and state laws
which delegate certain authorities to
mayors this dispute in georgia
is really unheard of that the mayor
wants to be
stricter than the governor wants her to
be and he wants a judge
to interfere uh with her decisions
the bottom line is no one on the planet
has the authority to compel you
to wear a mask unless you are entering
private property and they don't want to
do business with you without a mask
even though cities and states can pass
public health regulations right i mean
there can be a law
saying you got to wash your hands if you
work in a restaurant what's the
difference
because i well it depends on where
you're ordering me to wear
the mask and wash my hands if you're
requiring me to wash my hands before i
touch your food
if you're requiring me to wear a mask
before before i touch your food
that is an ordinary and reasonable
health regulation if i don't like the
regulation i go get another job
but if you're going to require me to
wear a mask in the streets and
i don't want you to think i'm a luddite
i do wear a mask wherever i go
because i think that the vouch is right
which is going to require me to wear a
mask
in the streets and i am not symptomatic
there's no legal basis for that
whatsoever
that's like requiring me to wear a pink
shirt instead of a blue one
uh the florida teachers union is suing
to stop reopening of schools next month
saying they're not protected enough
again is this another thing where it's
the eye of the beholder who decides
what protections are adequate they are
they argue there's evidence that
especially older kids can
transmit as easily or more easily even
than adults
and that this is a workplace safety
issue they have in my opinion i'm sorry
to say this because i want the schools
to open but they have a very strong case
the florida constitution expressly
requires
municipalities to maintain a safe
environment in the school new jersey has
the same language
this has produced many cases in new
jersey and in florida
requiring officials to bend over
backwards to assure
a safe and thorough education for the
governor to say
you don't have to wear a mask just come
to school is not going to wash and i'm
sure the courts are going to get
involved there
this there may be politics i mean the
the teachers union hates the governor
he's a conservative republican
and most labor unions don't like
conservative republican governors
i get that but i do believe that under
florida law they have a very strong case
and i think
they're likely to prevail uh there's
this kentucky couple
on house arrest because they wouldn't
they they tested positive for
coronavirus they refused to sign this
check-in order saying you know if we
travel we'll let you know or we won't
travel
um now they're on house arrest
this is a pro another profoundly
unconstitutional procedure
first of all there was no due process
there was no trial here
under the 5th and 14th amendments if the
government wants life liberty or
property
here liberty it has to afford you due
process due process means
the law was validly enacted by the
legislature
and it pre-existed whatever they said
you did or didn't do
that's not the case here this isn't a
law it's an executive
order of the governor due process also
means that only the legislature can
craft a punishment that's not the case
here the governor crafted it
due process means there's a trial which
are represented by lawyers
that's not what happened here so i mean
kentucky has to follow the basic
rudiments of federal law no matter what
its constitution says
and i've just given you three reasons
why they have not well in this couple
saying look we just we didn't want to
sign this agreement because we didn't
want to get in trouble say we had to
travel for an emergency or whatever it
was and they didn't want to put
themselves in
what they saw as legal jeopardy now
there is no way
legally as you're saying
constitutionally and just
temperamentally there's no way
a tracing program we talk about testing
and tracing being a way to contain this
virus
it's just never going to happen here
it's not going to happen in america
because we we have too much of a
freedom in in our natures and and in
and in our cultures it's it's just not
going to happen look there's only one
thing the government can make you sign
against your will
it's called an irs return everything
else you have the right to remain silent
which means you don't have to agree
you don't have to disagree andrew
napolitano fox news
senior judicial analyst judge thank you
very much always
always uh good to talk to you chris
thank you you too thanks judge have a
good day
bye-bye
[Music]
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana parino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirewall dissect
the ins and outs of national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
raiden review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
andy mccarthy
what's on your mind he shall take care
that the laws be faithfully executed
the constitution says that's the
president's job
but we're not hearing much about that
from the chattering classes
we hear plenty of blockading from the
media democrat complex
dutifully masquerading the rioting in
portland as mostly peaceful protest
and there is no shortage of faux outrage
over president trump's purported
trampling on state sovereignty by
dispatching federal agents to address
the mayhem
but we don't hear much about the
constitution
including from politicians such as rand
paul
who are want to pose as
constitutionalists
the provision quoted at the top of this
op-ed is from
article 2 section 3 of the constitution
it imposes on the president of the
united states the duty to
execute federal law the constitution
says the president
shall perform this obligation we're not
talking about an
option or something he may or may not do
depending on what he sees fit
it is a solemn duty it is what being the
chief executive
is all about the president has two
principle
closely related responsibilities
to provide for national security and to
see that the laws are enforced
the latter includes the protection of
federal property
and the execution of laws congress has
constitutionally enacted
to address violent crime enforcing
federal law
is an independent obligation of the
chief executive
consequently the president and the
justice department
never have to wait for a state to ask
for federal intervention
federal law enforcement agencies may and
routinely do
take investigative and enforcement
action within
state territory they need not provide
notice
much less ask for permission from the
state or its police agencies
federal officers in portland are not a
military force
they are deputized law enforcement
agents of the department of homeland
security
and other federal police agencies they
are not
as senator paul misleadingly suggests
rounding up people at will
they are making arrests based on
probable cause that laws enacted by
congress
have been violated equally without merit
is the complaint
that uniformed federal agents are
covering their names on their badges
and that other federal agents are acting
in an undercover capacity
it is a convention for uniform police to
display their names
along with their badges and assigned
numbers in normal peacetime conditions
but there is no constitutional right to
have federal police identify themselves
by name
or even identify themselves as police
in circumstances where police are being
targeted for assault
and harassment which includes being
doxxed by radicals
who use identifying information to
threaten police and their families
it is perfectly reasonable to withhold
the names of agents
notwithstanding the political demagogues
who would have us turn a blind eye to
violent crime
under the guise of honoring free
expression the trump administration has
the constitutional duty
to uphold federal law in portland
federal agents are faithfully executing
our nation's laws
this is andrew mccarthy fox news and
former federal
prosecutor
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion
you trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes